[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten guten abend
impfen was das zeug hält das ist die der
zentrale baustein der korona strategie
der neuen bundesregierung doch heute
abend wird bekannt der impfstoff wird
schon wieder knapp später mehr dazu ein
weiterer baustein ist der neue
expertenrat der sich heute zu seiner
ersten sitzung traf er hat versammelt
insgesamt 19 expertinnen und experten
darunter die virologen christian drosten
und hendrik strikt die in der
vergangenheit nicht immer einer meinung
war auch andere disziplinen sind
vertreten medizin physik psychologie
ethik an leiter eines gesundheitsamts
und ein landrat erster auftrag eine
stellungnahme zur omikron variante
zeitnah
heute blieb der rat stimmt äußerte sich
jedenfalls nicht öffentlich zu der
entscheidung die die gesundheitsminister
von bund und ländern trafen wer gepustet
ist muss sich künftig nicht mehr testen
lassen das soll jetzt bundesweit gelten
eine entscheidung die bei experten
außerhalb des rates durchaus auf kritik
stieß mal in ihlow und fabian köhler
berichten
wer bereits gebucht hat ist dafür
niedersachsen ohne test ins lokal das
land hat die 2g plus regel gelockert für
das personal und die meisten gäste eine
deutliche erleichterung
aus unternehmerischer sicht würde ich
sagen ist die variante so wie sie jetzt
gerade ist gar nicht schlecht aus
pandemischer würde ich sagen ist eine
testpflicht auch für gehostete sinnvoll
und auch eigentlich notwendig weil wir
auch gäste haben die schon älteres
semester sind und die fühlen sich damit
schlicht und ergreifend sicherer in
niedersachsen hatte anfang dezember als
eines der ersten bundesländer die tests
pflicht für dreifach geimpfte aufgehoben
hintergrund waren engpässe beim testen
lange schlangen vor testzentren diese
strategie der landesregierung sollte
auch ein anreiz sein wir stellen fest
seitdem wir sie umsetzen haben wir auch
noch mal noch mal viel mehr nachfrage
bei den booster impfung die hälfte der
booster impfung niedersachsen sind
passiert seitdem wir diese regelung
haben als dritt geimpfter ohne test ins
restaurant oder ins kino bislang gibt es
keine einheitliche booster regel in den
ländern neben niedersachsen erlauben
bisher rheinland-pfalz thüringen
baden-württemberg bayern und das
saarland gebürsteten menschen den zugang
ohne weiteren test die
gesundheitsminister der länder haben
sich nun darauf verständigt diese
ausnahme für alle bundesländer zu
empfehlen wir haben uns heute in diesem
antrag darauf geeinigt dass personen mit
erhaltener auffrischungsimpfung ab deren
vollständiger wirksamkeit von der test
pflicht im rahmen der zweig plus
regelung befreit werden sollen wichtig
ist für den zutritt in medizinische und
pflegerische einrichtung soll es weiter
bei einer test verpflichtung bleiben
gerade jetzt die tests schlecht
abzuschaffen das war ein fehler warnen
experten
die entscheidung der gesundheitsminister
ist unverantwortlich omikron hat
deutschland erreicht
und jetzt in denen die testpflicht fällt
wollen wir die pandemie im blindflug
besiegen das ist nicht hilfreich und das
ist ein weihnachtsgeschenk das uns im
januar schwer auf die füße fallen wird
doch der neue gesundheitsminister
verteidigt diese strategie es ist
tatsächlich so dass jemand der frisch
geputzt hat ist ein sehr geringes risiko
dreht sich zu infizieren und dann noch
viel geringeres risiko trägt sich so zu
infizieren dass er für andere ansteckend
ist jedoch gebe es bislang zu wenig
booster impfstoff zu gering sei die
bestellte menge durch den bund so
lauterbach heute er will nun auch direkt
mit den herstellern verhandeln die
gastrobranche ist bei und sichert durch
das ständige nachjustieren der chor ohne
regeln wenn sich alle zwei tage die
regeln ändern und man sich an nichts
festes gewöhnen kann oder sich darauf
einstellen kann also die
planungssicherheit geht dadurch komplett
verloren kurz vor weihnachten hätte er
einen wunsch durchdacht einmal alles
runter zu fahren um dann im frühjahr
wieder durchzustarten und
der vorsitzende der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz
bayerns minister klaus holetschek ist
mir jetzt zugeschaltet schön genannt
nach münchen
guten abend vor schluss zum also keine
tests nicht mehr für gebucht hatte sehr
überzeugt wirkten sehr hologic heute bei
der pressekonferenz von ihrer eigenen
entscheidung nicht die ja auch wirklich
nicht ohne risiken ist wahr dass jetzt
nur mein eindruck oder lege ich damit
nicht ganz so falsch nein ich bin schon
überzeugt wir haben ja abgewogen wir
hatten eine wissenschaftliche empfehlung
auch des bundesgesundheitsministers und
dies verantwortbar und vertretbar
natürlich müssen wir ohne krone im auge
behalten das ist eine herausforderung
und unbekannte und mir war auch wichtig
dass wir bei altenheimen und
pflegeheimen und dem krankenhaus diese
testpflicht beibehalten ja so ist es
also altenheime pflegeheime da gilt es
nicht nicht bei medizinischen
einrichtungen sie haben selbst gesagt es
muss jetzt ständig beobachtet werden in
zwei monaten soll das ganze spätestens
wieder auf den prüfstand kommen hat
schon das gefühl da ist jetzt sehr sehr
viel vorsicht nötig dann sagen sie doch
mal warum machen sie es dann überhaupt
es ist eine empfehlung aus infektiologie
gesicht es ist vertretbar es ist ein
zusätzlicher ins anreiz sich postern zu
lassen es schont auch die test
kapazitäten und es gibt schon gute
gründe dafür dass jetzt zu tun und
deswegen haben wir das abgewogen und
dann so entschieden aber dann überwiegen
eigentlich nicht die epidemiologischen
sondern die anderen gründe also anstoß
für die poster kampagne
das ist sicher auch ein grund aber ich
glaube der bundesgesundheitsminister hat
es noch einmal deutlich gemacht und
hertz auch rückgekoppelt mit weiteren
experten dass es eben vertretbar ist und
dass es auch so ist das bei dreifach
geimpften dann die frage des antigen
schnelltest und der validität auch eine
wichtige rolle spielt von daher haben
wir es wirklich diskutiert und sind dann
zu diesem entschluss gekommen aber man
hört nun gerade eben bei zweifach
geimpften und gemusterten immer häufiger
von durchbrüchen ist es da nicht gerade
fatal wenn man jetzt da die tests
streicht dann fühlt sich jeder gewusst
hätte umso sicherer und steckt
möglicherweise dann eben doch andere an
naja wird deswegen haben wir auch
ausnahmen beschlossen zum beispiel
bezüglich variable gruppen und wir
wollen das hat sehr engmaschige auch
beobachten aber ich glaube unter den
blickwinkeln und der abwägung die wir
einfach heute vorgenommen haben ist es
tatsächlich vertretbar und deswegen ist
die entscheidung meine ich jetzt aus dem
gesichtspunkt richtig
nun hat man gehört aus ihrer sitzung
heute mit dem bundesgesundheitsminister
lauterbach dass er von mängeln von
fehlendem impfstoff gerade im beginn des
nächsten jahres berichtet hat wie
gravierend ist dass und wie stark
gefährdet dieser mangelnde impfstoff
jetzt diese poster kampagne also der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat ja
sozusagen inventur gemacht und hat uns
volk berichtet dass wir noch mehr
impfstoff brauchen das will ich noch mal
unterstreichen wir haben da auch
ausdrücklich ermutigt alle schritte zu
gehen auch in direkten gesprächen mit
impfstoffherstellern mehr impfstoff zu
besorgen auch angepassten an die
mutation weil wir ja eben das boostern
tatsächlich im mittelpunkt haben wir
reden über eine allgemeine impfpflicht
und ich glaube da haben wir lieber zu
viel als zu wenig impfstoff deswegen
müssen wir da noch mal in die
beschaffung gehen
glauben sie dass die impfpflicht dann
unter diesen neuen vorzeichen überhaupt
nachkommen kann ich denke schon die
impfpflicht ist wie stieg und die
diskussion dazu muss jetzt geführt
werden und auch eine entscheidung muss
herbeigeführt werden und ich bin
optimistisch dass es uns gemeinsam
gelingt auch weiteren impfstoff zu
organisieren ich glaube man muss jetzt
auch einfach die direkten wege noch mal
gehen und das hat herr professor
lauterbach versichert und wir
unterstützen ihn von den ländern auch
sehr dabei aber es im nachhinein dann
nochmal ein versäumnis des früheren
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen
offenbar wenn zu wenig bestellt worden
ist ich glaube dass ich jetzt nicht die
frage wo was bestellt worden ist im
moment sondern die frage ist wie können
wir noch mehr beschaffen und ich denke
es wichtig dass wir transparenz im
system haben das brauchen wir auch weil
wir merken auch der impfstoff kommt
manchmal nicht dort an wohin sollte über
die einzelnen kanäle wir kriegen immer
wieder rückmeldungen auch von ärzten das
zu wenig geliefert würde ich bin sehr
dafür dass wir da transparenz herstellen
und jetzt auf jeden fall weiteren
impfstoff beschaffen dann noch mal
zurück zu der heute getroffenen regel
also wir hören zu wenig zu wenig
impfstoff
glauben sie gleichwohl dass diese regel
bestand haben kann auch im angesicht von
omikron was jetzt möglicherweise zunimmt
und gefährlicher wird also omikron muss
man genau beobachten
deswegen begrüße ich sehr dass der
expertenrat der neu eingerichtet worden
ist von der bundesregierung jetzt
zeitnah auch uns mehr daten zur
verfügung stellt auch erkenntnisse was
bedeutet das genau wir wissen dass
omikron hoch infektiös ist wir wissen
noch ein bisschen wenig über
krankheitsverläufe und andere parameter
das brauchen wir aber dringend und
tatsächlich eine gute beurteilung der
lage auch zu haben gut vorerst muss man
auf sicht fahren kleine schritte gehen
wir haben bayerns minister klaus
holetschek gehört vielen dank gerne
das gespräch haben wir aufgezeichnet
wenn sich zu beginn einer
legislaturperiode in berlin die neuen
bundestagsausschüsse bilden dann ist das
immer anlass für diskussionen drei um
dürfen die fraktionen nach größe wählen
welchen ausschuss sie führen wollen es
geht um fach aber mindestens genauso
sehr um machtfragen dieses mal schlägt
das prozedere besonders hohe wellen denn
ausgerechnet der innenausschuss
zuständig für themen wie migration
extremismus und auch die kontrolle der
sicherheitsbehörden soll einen
vorsitzenden von der afg bekommen die
wird in teilen selbst vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet die
empörung ist laut und richtet sich auch
gegen grüne und fdp die es in der hand
gehabt hätten diese zuordnung zu
verhindern morgen nun kommt es zum
schwur aus berlin david guetta hat da
ist sie wieder die gretchenfrage im
parlament der umgang mit der afg darf
eine demokratisch gewählte partei die in
teilen vom verfassungsschutz beobachtet
wird ein ausschuss leiten der auch die
repräsentiert die sich um sicherheit und
schutz der demokratie bemühen
wie hält er es als gewerkschaft der
polizei für äußerst problematisch dass
man diejenigen nicht unterstützt die für
die aufrechterhaltung der demokratie des
rechtsstaates anstehende brauchen
jemanden der im innenausschuss den
vorsitz hat der nicht spaltet sondern
der miteinander rede die unsere
gesellschaft zusammenhält nach und nach
hatten die fraktionen ihre
ausschussvorsitzenden gezogen die union
als größte oppositionspartei haushalt
die spd außen die grünen vor der fdp an
welt nicht innen sondern europa wohl
auch als trostpflaster für den beim
minister poker leer ausgegangenen anton
hofreiter und stehen jetzt massiv in der
kritik erklärungsversuche die erste
priorität war den europaausschuss zu
ziehen weil klar ist dass auch dort sehr
viele innen und europa und
außenpolitische entscheidungen getroffen
werden
so blieb der afg ausgerechnet der
zugriff auf den vorsitz des
innenausschusses
heute wählt sie ihren kandidaten martin
hess hauptkommissar enger weidl
vertrauter der sich im plenum zu
kleinkriminalität und migration schon
mal so äußert das sind kriegsmaschinen
diese mit ihrer vorteilen
migrationspolitik ungehindert in unser
land lassen und das ist ein skandal für
den fall meiner wahl werde ich
selbstverständlich diesen vorsitz
neutral und überparteilich auch
entsprechend ausfüllen fairness auch im
politischen betrieb in der politischen
auseinandersetzung ist mir ein sehr
wichtiges anliegen
parteiübergreifend regt sich widerstand
es laufen gespräche wie morgen der
eigentlich nur formal zu benennende
innenausschussvorsitzende in eine wahl
geschickt und womöglich verhindert
werden könnte für mich ist das deshalb
schwierig weil die afg in teilen vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet wird und
wir natürlich mit dem innenausschuss
noch die ausschussvorsitzende wir
kontrollieren das innenministerium die
nachgelagerten behörden und dazu gehört
auch das bundesamt für verfassungsschutz
der ausschussvorsitzende bekommt
privilegiert informationen aus dem
innenministerium wird oftmals als erstes
informiert aber wer dort sitzt um
alleine rechte agenda zu betreiben oder
eben auch in einer scharnierfunktion zu
der mobilisierungs fähigen extrem
rechten auf der straße der wird diese
information nutzen auch ob die
nominierten vorsitzenden für die
ausschüsse gesundheit und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit durchgehend
offen zudem sorgt die nominierung
einfacher ausschussmitglieder für
empörung etwa der fall eines ehemaligen
bundeswehrsoldaten der vom bundeswehr
geheimdienst mrd als extremist
eingestuft wird und nun in den
verteidigungsausschuss zwei hatten aus
einem afghanistan-einsatz was meine
informationen sind über den er 2009 10
beendet hatte ein gespräch mit 2 mrd
kollegen und nach die nach diesem
gespräch wurde er als rechtsextremist
eingestuft ohne dass bislang ein
disziplinarverfahren eröffnet wurde
insofern verhöhnt und cfd gerade jemand
rein zu schicken der vom mrd als
extremist bezeichnet worden ist und das
ist schon beunruhigend denn wir haben
mit material zu tun mit unterlagen zu
tun die zum teil auch geheim gestuft
sind weil sie die sicherheit unseres
landes unseres kontinentes betrifft
demokratische faire teilhabe einer
partei die die anderen mehrheitlich als
demokratie feinde sehen der umgang mit
der afg strapaziert mehr denn je das
parlament
und in den nachrichten kommen wir jetzt
noch mal zurück auf das thema ko runde
lang aus wegen der pandemie kann der
karneval in nordrhein westfalen auch in
dieser saison nicht wie gewohnt gefeiert
werden freiwillig hätten vertreter des
organisierten karneval zugesagt auf
sitzungen und bälle in sälen zu
verzichten erklärte
nrw-ministerpräsident wüst zugleich geht
die bundesweite inzidenz weiter zurück
sie lag heute bei
375 nach zuvor rund 390 das rk ii
registrierte 30 1823 neuinfektionen
innerhalb eines tages
5236 weniger als vor einer woche hoch
die aktuelle zahl der korona todesopfer
473 menschen starben binnen 24 stunden
großbritannien kämpft bereits mit einer
neuen infektionswelle durch die omikron
variante insgesamt wurden heute im
vereinigten königreich mehr als 59 1600
neue infektionen registriert der
fünfthöchste wert seit beginn der
pandemie die regierung von premier
johnson brachte schärfere corona
maßnahmen ins unterhaus ein gegen
massiven widerstand aus den eigenen
reihen mit den stimmen der
oppositionellen labour partei wurden
soeben eine verschärfung der masken
pflicht eine impfpflicht für das
medizinische personal sowie 3g nachweise
für großveranstaltungen beschlossen der
online-dienst telegramm steht zunehmend
in der kritik der militante corona
leugne sowie rechtsextreme sich über
diesen messenger-dienst organisieren
sollten staatliche maßnahmen geprüft
werden forderte thüringens spd
innenminister meier im zdf auf dieser
sozialen plattform werde auch zu gewalt
aufgerufen
telegramm sitzt in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten und löscht bislang
keine beiträge die hass und hetze
enthalten ein ausführlicher bericht dazu
später im heute-journal update die union
hat verfassungsbeschwerde gegen den
geplanten nachtragshaushalt der ampel
koalition angekündigt
cdu/csu-fraktionschef brinkhaus sagte es
sei höchst bedenklich nicht genutzte
kreditermächtigungen für andere vorhaben
zu verwenden der bundestag hatte wegen
der korona krise in diesem jahr 240
milliarden euro neue schulden genehmigt
60 milliarden mehr als nötig diese will
finanzminister lindner als kredite
aufnehmen und in den klima vor stecken
der damit deutlich an wächst auf über 76
milliarden
in leipzig wird nach der beschädigung
einer moschee wegen schweren
landfriedensbruchs ermittelt aus einer
gruppe von etwa 70 vermummten waren
gestern abend fensterscheiben
eingeschlagen wurden die tatverdächtigen
warfen flaschen und zündeten pyrotechnik
die polizei stellte bei 12 der
randalierer die personalien fest und
ermittelt ob die moschee gezielt
beschädigt wurde der zuständige islam
verband ditib erklärte es handele sich
um den achten angriff binnen weniger
jahre
der diktator rächt sich an seinen
stärksten widersacher
so deutete die belarussische
oppositionsführerin svetlana d janowski
heute das urteil gegen ihren ehemann 18
jahre lagerhaft wegen der organisation
von massenunruhen
sergej iwanow ski wollte bei den
präsidentschaftswahlen im letzten sommer
gegen präsident lukaschenka antreten
nach seiner festnahme übernahm seine
frau swetlana und wurde zu einer ikone
der opposition ihren protest aus dem
litauischen exil schlossen sich heute
auch kritiker im westen an die deutsche
außenministerin bernburg sprach von
einem skandalösen urteil und forderte
die sofortige freilassung aller
politischen gefangenen aus moskau
christian sen
als letzter der sechs angeklagten wird
sergej iwanow ski in den gerichtshof ich
geführt demonstrativ dreht er sich mit
dem rücken zu den kameras weil sie
diktator lukaschenko gefährlich wurden
müssen die männer für lange zeit ins
gefängnis
18 jahre so lautet das urteil gegen
tiere noch ski der vorwurf unter anderem
organisation von massenunruhen und
anstiftung zu sozialem hass zum
verhängnis wurde ihm dass er lukaschenko
2020 als präsidentschaftskandidat
herausfordern wollte ich bin sergej
kirow sybille russischer geschäftsmann
und blogger ich möchte bekannt geben
dass ich als kandidat an
präsidentschaftswahlkampf teilnehmen
werde doch dazu kommt es nicht
turnovszky wird festgenommen und an
seine stelle tritt seine frau swetlana
tier an oskar die bis dahin mit politik
gar nichts zu tun hatte gemeinsam mit
maria colleoni koffer die mittlerweile
zu elf jahren lagerhaft verurteilt wurde
und veronika zepp carlo forderten die
drei frauen lukaschenko heraus sap carlo
musste das land verlassen genauso wie
swetlana tieren of skye die als
wahlsiegerin der umstrittenen
präsidentschaftswahl gilt sie musste vor
dem lukaschenko regime fliehen und
kämpft weiter für belarus und ihren mann
das urteil bedeutet dass mein tapferer
und wundervoller mann ein persönlicher
feind von lukaschenko wurde der hat
rache genommen wegen der starken
stellung meines mannes level millionen
von bürgern ein anführer sein könnte
auch der mann von marina abramovic wurde
heute verurteilt 14 jahre bekam der
langjährige oppositionspolitiker nikolai
statkewitsch ab und zu schreiben sie
sich briefe
ich denke dass es für nicolai wichtig
ist zu wissen dass es mir gut geht und
mir ist wichtig dass er spürt dass sich
bei ihm mit wir kommunizieren
ausschließlich über briefe in den mehr
als 560 tagen die er hinter gittern
verbracht hat hatten wir nur ein
einziges treffen
das harte strafmaß heute das sonst nur
mörder bekommen so lukaschenko gegner ab
solch ein urteil gehört zum mechanismus
alle einzuschüchtern die anders denken
oder unzufrieden sind heute wird nicht
nur gegen die opposition oder die
zivilgesellschaft gekämpft sondern
grundsätzlich gegen andersdenkende es
gibt massen sauberes aktionen im ganzen
land
[Musik]
maria callas die koffer oder
es sind drei prominente namen aber in
behla russischen gefängnissen sitzen
hunderte weitere politische gefangene
aus dem weg geräumt von diktator
alexander lukaschenko
und jetzt noch einmal nachrichten
gundula gause die pandemie und
lieferprobleme belasten die deutsche
wirtschaft und auch die
konjunkturerwartungen das münchner ifo
institut senkte seine prognose für das
nächste jahr deutlich um 1,4 auf ein
plus von nur 3,7 prozent besonders
betroffen die deutschen maschinenbauer
valerie die trotz allem optimistisch
sind worauf gründet deren zuversicht die
gründet auf den prall gefüllten
auftragsbüchern das geschäft der
maschinenbauer brummt nämlich seit
monaten schon ja darunter auch
umfangreiche großaufträge komplette
fabriken oder teile davon und kommendes
jahr will die branche die korona krise
voll abgeschüttelt haben bremsklotz
allein ist der materialmangel weil
wichtige vorprodukte fehlen können viele
aufträge nicht im gewohnten tempo
abgearbeitet werden in einer vdi umfrage
unter 500 unternehmen klagt die
überwältigende mehrheit über
lieferketten probleme
86 prozent der firmen fehlen
elektronikteile 65 prozent warten auf
metalle wie kupfer und stahl 46 prozent
auf kunststoffe und gummi die
maschinenbauer gehören zu den größten
arbeitgebern in deutschland sie planen
in den kommenden monaten ihr personal
aufzustocken
doch auch hier gibt es ein weit
verbreitetes problem der
fachkräftemangel den bezeichnen die
maschinenbau als eine der ganz großen
herausforderungen der zukunft die sich
als fortschritt bremse puppen könnte auf
die bremse treten auch anleger an der
frankfurter börse der dax heute deutlich
im minus die amerikanische notenbank
wird sich morgen zum thema zinsen und
hohe inflation äußern ja und vermutlich
wird die fed eine straffere geldpolitik
ankündigen für die aktienmärkte wäre das
keine so gute nachricht vielen dank
valerie in frankfurt zwei meldungen vom
sport die deutschen handballerinnen
haben gerade eben das viertelfinale der
wm in barcelona verloren die
nationalmannschaft unterlag den
spanischen gastgeberinnen 21 zu 26 und
in der fußball bundesliga wird schon
heute gespielt am abend trat bayern
münchen bereits beim vfb stuttgart an
der tabellenführer sicherte sich den
herbstmeistertitel mit dem klaren
auswärtssieg 15 0
nach den verheerenden tornados in den
usa ist die zahl der todesopfer auf
mindestens
88 gestiegen allein in kentucky kamen 74
menschen ums leben teilte der gouverneur
mit die einsatzkräfte suchten weiter
nach etwa noch 100 vermissten unter den
trümmern
präsident biden hat einen besucher in
den schwer getroffenen gebieten für
morgen angekündigt erklärungen zu der
tornado serie in den usa gleich im
wetterbericht
ein internationales forscherteam warnt
vor einem dramatischen wandel am straits
plätze im westen der antarktis infolge
des klimawandels
studien deuten demnach darauf hin dass
ein im meer schwimmende teil des
gletschers bereits innerhalb von weniger
als zehn jahren zersplittern könnte
grund dafür sei warmes wasser dass
aufgrund der erderwärmung unter dem
gletscher gelangen
das tagebuch der anne frank es ist das
bis heute beeindruckende und berührende
zeugnis eines jungen jüdischen mädchens
das dem schrecken ihrer zeit zu trotzen
versucht die unmenschlichkeit des
naziterrors gerade für nachgeborene
junge menschen für gemacht anne frank
starb
im alter von 15 jahren im kz bergen
belsen ihr versteck in amsterdam dass
sie mit sieben weiteren verfolgten
teilte darunter ihrem vater war
aufgeflogen er überlebte den holocaust
als einziger der gruppe ein
niederländischer historiker hat nun die
schicksale auch der andere nach verfolgt
die so über anne franks tagebuch hinaus
ein gesicht bekommen serafin reiber und
christian kitsch berichten
das ehemalige durchgangslager westerbork
im nordosten der niederlande
von hier wurde anne frank nach auschwitz
deportiert eine von
102.000 niederländischen jüdinnen und
juden roma und sinti 75 jahre danach
will er acht ihrer geschichten zu ende
erzählen
ich will die schicksale erzählen der
acht im hinterhaus untergetauchten
und so genau wie möglich nachvollziehen
wie sie in den unterschiedlichen
konzentrationslager kommen sind und wie
als sieben von den acht dort gestorben
sind von bender beckmanns buch knüpft
dort an wo das wissen der meisten
aufhört das hinterhaus in amsterdam
hinter diesem bücherregal hielten sich
anne margot edith und otto frank
versteckt zusammen mit fritz pfeffer und
der familie van pels zwei lange
verzweifelte jahre dann der verrat die
festnahme sieben von ihnen ermordeten
die nazis von bender will wissen wann wo
wie genau zum beispiel peter van pels
geboren 1926 in osnabrück akribisch
recherchiert von bender seinen
leidensweg der deutsche war in die
niederlande geflogen am vierten august
1944 die verhaftung verschleppt nach
westerbork von dort nach auschwitz wo er
überlebt bis zum 18 januar 1945 dann
mauthausen häftlingsnummer 119 16 24
tage später außenlager melk wieder
mauthausen tod am 10 mai kurz nach der
befreiung
den millionen toten ein je individuelles
gesicht geben ihre persönliche
geschichte zu erzählen im massensterben
dieser ansatz verstärkt sich in der
holocaust forschung er will eine
vorstellung bekommen von den leidensweg
in dieser nacht oder genießen aus dem
tagebuch das gelingt nicht indem man
sich nur mit dem historischen wissen
beschäftigt andererseits sind die
fragmentarischen erinnerungen auch zu
gering und das von bender blickt man
gelingt es dies beides zu verknüpfen und
da eine kluge zusammenschau darzustellen
an orten wie diesen dem durchgangslager
westerbork verloren tausende auf dem weg
in den tod auch ihre individualität
auslöschung war das ziel der mörder das
ziel der erinnerung sollte es sein die
persönlichkeit jedes opfers zu erhalten
ich glaube es fehlte bisher weil die
erzählung über eine frank bisher richtig
dass auch das domain von den
journalistischen bereich war wohl
der fokus doch war auf die befragen
individueller einiger individueller
zeugen und die geschichtswissenschaft
sich als auch viel mehr mit größeren
historischen fragen beschäftigt hat
deshalb wurden kaum die leidenswege
einzelner geschildert doch es gab
millionen anne franks hier in westerbork
erinnert an jedes deportierte opfer eine
stele ein eigenes kleines denkmal
immerhin
so viel vom heute journal für den moment
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit 37 grad es
heute über den arbeitsalltag im verkauf
berichtet supermarkt bäckerei kaufhaus
da kannst du einpacken heißt der titel
der reportage wir empfehlen sie sehr und
ich muss ganz kurz korrigieren dass es
natürlich der vfb stuttgart ist der
gegen die bayern verloren hat gegen
mitternacht ist hier wieder zeit für
unser heute-journal update mit nasa und
morgen übernimmt an dieser stelle claus
kleber tschüss schön
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter tornados im
dezember kommt schon mal vor aber dieser
massive ausbruch in den usa mit
katastrophale zerstörungen ist
rekordverdächtig
extremwetter nimmt zu und werden
teilweise durch die globale erhitzung
verstärkt zu heizen sich die ozeane auf
und in diesem fall war der golf von
mexiko bis zu vier grad wärmer als
normal wärme luft mehr feuchtigkeit auf
und wird die treibstoff verheerend wenn
sie auf deutlich kältere luft aus dem
norden trifft der jetstream wurde mit
den temperatur gegensätzen zusätzlich
verstärkt und so bildeten sich extreme
gewitter so genannte super zählen die
über mehrere staaten zogen und circa 35
tornados erzeugten
komplette anderes wetter bei uns nämlich
deutlich ruhiger und mit ziemlich vielen
wolken im norden deutschlands dazu kommt
etwas regen auf das hauptsächlich
sprühregen also viel ist es nicht nach
süden bildet sich nebel an den alpen
wird es am kältesten sein mit leichtem
frost bis minus 1 grad sonst ist es
milder richtung mitte vor allem nach
westen hin und richtung niederrhein bei
acht grad morgen im tagesverlauf
weiterhin viele wolken im norden und
etwas sprühregen
ganz im süden sonnenschein und auch
richtung nordsee zeigt sich die sonne
mal bei höchsten temperaturen von vier
grad an den alpen und im norden neun bis
zehn grad deutlich milder
die kommenden tage am donnerstag etwas
regen im osten sonst aber auch mal
sonnenschein bei zwei bis zehn grad und
ab freitag ähnliche wetterverhältnisse
ein schöner abend